[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
[CROWD TALKING]
>> HEY, GIRL, I'M JUST CHECKING
TO SEE IF YOU ARE HERE YET, AND
I DON'T SEE YOU SO --
I'M JUST GOING TO GRAB A SEAT AT
THE BAR, ALL RIGHT.
SO JUST FIND ME WHEN YOU GET
HERE.
BYE.
>> EXCUSE ME, IS THIS SEAT
TAKEN?
>> OH.
>> I'M SORRY, I'M NOT LIKE A
GROSS GUY TRYING TO HIT ON YOU
OR ANYTHING.
I JUST -- I CAN'T FIND A SEAT.
>> OKAY, YEAH, SURE.
>> THANKS.
BELIEVE ME, I KNOW THIS PLACE IS
FILLED WITH SKEEZY GUYS.
>> I THINK THE WHOLE WORLD IS.
>> I THINK ONE IS OUR PRESIDENT.
>> DO NOT REMIND ME.
>> I'M DAVE.
>> I'M MICHELLE.
>> I HAVE GOT TO SAY I REALLY
LIKE YOUR T-SHIRT.
>> OH.
YEAH, WELL, THE FUTURE IS
FEMALE.
>> I KNOW.
LOOK.
>> NO!
OKAY, WELL DAVE ON BEHALF OF ALL
WOMEN, WE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
>> HEY, DO YOU MAYBE WANT TO
HANG OUT SOME TIME?
>> YOU MEAN LIKE A DATE.
>> YEAH, LIKE A DATE.
>> UM -- NO, THANK YOU.
>> OKAY, BITCH.
I'M WEARING THIS SHIRT, AND YOU
WON'T EVEN LET ME NUT.
I FOLLOWED ALL THE RULES.
>> NIGHTMARE.
>> YEAH.
>> SORRY ABOUT THAT.
YOU ALL RIGHT?
>> YEAH, YEAH, I'M FINE.
THANK YOU.
>> YOU FROM AROUND HERE?
>> SORRY, I DIDN'T MEAN THAT IN
LIKE A SKEEZY, WHERE DO YOU LIVE
SORT OF WAY.
>> NO, IT'S OKAY, I'M FROM D.C.
>> OH NO WAY, I WAS ACTUALLY
JUST THERE FOR THE WOMEN'S
MARCH.
>> REALLY?
>> YEAH, YEAH WE RENTED A BUS,
AND BROUGHT DOWN LIKE A HUNDRED
PEOPLE FROM THE NEIGHBORHOOD WHO
DIDN'T HAVE A RIDE.
IT WAS HONESTLY, ONE OF THE BEST
DAYS OF MY LIFE.
>> WOW, YOU'RE VERY NICE.
>> WOULD YOU WANT TO COME TO MY
PLACE?
>> OH, NO, THANK YOU.
>> BITCH.
>> WHAT?
>> I FREAKING MARCHED FOR YOU,
AND YOU WON'T GET DOWN ON THIS?
>> HEY, SHE'S NOT INTO IT MAN.
>> FINE.
>> GOD.
>> GUYS LIKE THAT ARE WHY WE
NEED A WOMAN IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
ENOUGH OF US MEN, RIGHT, WE HAD
OUR SHOT.
SORRY, I'M A BROKEN RECORD.
I WORKED FOR HILARY.
>> YOU DID.
I LOVE HILLARY.
>> YEAH.
HEY, CAN I ASK YOU A QUESTION,
SINCE WE BOTH LOVE HILLARY?
>> YEAH, SURE.
>> WOULD YOU WANT TO LOOK AT MY
BALLS?
>> EW, NO.
>> BITCH.
>> WHAT?
PLEASE, BUT IT'S NOT FAIR.
>> OKAY, BUDDY.
THAT'S ENOUGH.
MOVE ALONG.
I AM SO SORRY ABOUT MY FELLOW
MAN.
OH, YOU KNOW WHAT -- DO YOU BY
ANY CHANCE FOLLOW KAMALA HARRIS
ON TWITTER?
>> YEAH, I DO.
>> DO YOU WANT TO EAT MY BUTT.
>> NO.
>> BITCH.
NO.
>> AMY, I'M SO GLAD YOU ARE
HERE.
>> I'M SORRY I'M LATE.
THESE GUYS ARE HORRIBLE.
>> YEAH, TELL ME ABOUT IT.
THANK YOU FOR SAVING ME.
I LOVE YOU.
>> OH YOU DO?
>> YEAH.
>> TOUCH MY [ BLEEP ]?
>> WHAT, NO.
>> BITCH.
[ APPLAUSE ]